for me the sounds of the city have
always kind of made their way into the
music I've made I constantly find some
abstract like inspiration in the train
system so somehow the community aspect
of being around people on a regular
basis and the sounds of the tracks and
the light off the lake I think that all
of these things are things that
subliminally affect how we all make
music the city plays a huge role in my
artwork life I'm constantly just
inspired by buildings and people walking
around I spent a lot of time taking
photographs of walls and concrete and
all those surfaces end up as layers and
the work I do so like in the music where
we have layers of sound for me the work
becomes more realistic as I add layers
of city grime on to the work